[Music]
three
two one action hey guys welcome back to
off the record where we talk about
whatever we
want and we got the beautiful gorgeous
amazing nikki blades back
i brushed my hair today you smell so
good thank you like so good what are you
wearing
flower bomb where did you get it
is that marc jacobs i had to think i was
like that was a gift
oh who gave it to you
i had a man at one point in time oh i
had a man
did you spray it because you missed him
no
oh he got this for me
it because that's the only one i have
and i'm too lazy to buy my own
yeah i really i really am lazy on buying
my own perfume i don't
i don't buy any either i i
buy your own perfume no no
i don't have any perfume no you wear
cologne you don't
i do but why do you say it like that
like he needs it
that's what it sounds like right it's
kind of like he does
trust me i didn't mean for it to come
out like that i was like
oh really no i was just saying like he
doesn't have a signature smell
kind of thing that's it yeah i have
cologne
but i don't wear i had the same one for
like
nine years already i've had the same
perfume honestly for as long as i can
remember
because i don't what occasions do you
wear perfume because i i don't wear
cologne but i do have cologne
i gave them one whenever i have to be in
public when i have to deal with other
human beings i'm like okay
that's so nice i used to be better about
my perfume because
i i had a lot of perfumes i had like a
mini little
collection of them because i really like
the bottles too yeah the bottles are
pretty
and now i just don't what's your smell
oh um my favorite one for a long time
was
ah oh i like the juicy couture one oh
that's a good one
uh i also like tommy girl it smells
really good i got him tommy
for men mm-hmm so like we can match or
whatever hold on
look at the camera and keep blinking
this yeah your whole hair was moving
because of the thing it keeps doing that
thank you
yeah this it's the freaking cow like
that i have two cowlicks
on both sides so no matter which way i i
don't smell bad
no there's a difference between like i
didn't wear deodorant
you wear your dress i don't wear
deodorant are you a natural you're like
i don't wear anything
you don't smell he doesn't smell smell
me then that means you eat
really well then do you eat one not
always but then
i'd be doing juice cleanses and stuff
because then every month i have to do it
do you feel like you stink when you eat
weird food
um i don't know garlic i smell that on
yeah i eat raw garlic
that's the only time i think i've ever
smelled you is that is raw garlic
yeah yeah i don't know i i
i don't know i'm pretty disgusting no
when we go to vegas and you get all
dressed up and you wear a suit and stuff
you do you do tend to put cologne and i
do remember that oh yeah
that's the cherry on the cake because
i'm in vegas i'm like i don't want to
smell like cigarettes
do you think that a guy shouldn't wear
cologne every day so kind of like one
day he'll smell better or switch it up
for different types of clones
i've dated somebody who was obsessed
with cologne and he had a variety he
loves
is he middle eastern he was mexican okay
but he was like
yeah obsessed with his cologne he had a
really i mean he always smelled good and
he would switch it up because he would
be like do you like this one do you like
this one
so it was a good thing right just
pleasant to be around i loved it
was it ever too much because i always
feel like when i'm wearing cologne
sometimes i'm like tired of the smell
i'm just like oh
it's supposed to be a little bit sweet
more than one you get to switch it up
depending on the occasion he was
he was the type that he has his cologne
he loves smelling good he loves being
clean
so he always it matched like whatever he
was wearing his cologne matched his
outfit so you have something a little
bit more casual a little more daytime
and then you go into whatever outfit
i'm gonna go [ __ ] some fools up this is
my [ __ ] people this is my fight columns
strangely enough there are some colognes
that really make you
feel a little extra and i would wear his
cologne sometimes
me too i would wear that alone in high
school because i love how it smells
so good i want to mix these he would use
uh
the versace one the versace clone and
then like the
there's the dolce gabbana was a really
good one yeah yeah
i think i have a really sensitive smell
because i don't like cologne because it
bothers me
but i do like the sweeter stuff like the
like chemical black or cold water or
whatever
i can't do the spicy stuff yeah yeah the
musky
like like a russian mobster smell you
know like and people associate
scent with memories so so a lot of that
you know happens uh you asked me if i
sprayed it because i missed him
i've had his cologne before and do that
instead so if i'm feeling some type of
way i wouldn't put on the one that you
bought me because that's that's for me
but you spray them and you're like hmm
on the pillow and then just close it i
have done that i was in a long distance
relationship so he would we were
thinking
yeah he was long distance definitely did
the cologne the cologne spray because
it's like they're always there i don't
need somebody to be physically with me
all the time
but that scent is sometimes just enough
for you okay i'm cool
is that why girls ask for like your
shirt and stuff
because then they can just put it over
the pillow and then like [ __ ] it
yeah i think they smelled it oh nope
nope would you eyes are the ones that
usually [ __ ] pillows right because you
you're really
i think a lot of fabric things yeah
sounds like there's just a lot of things
you
kind of doesn't discriminate when you
when you said the neck part i was like
you've definitely put your penis i've
done it
i've actually [ __ ] tried to [ __ ] a lot
of creases before
yeah i can see you saying babe let me
massage you and it just means like water
bottle to them
[Laughter]
babe let me let me let me give you a
head massage i've tried a lot
i'm a i'm an explorer you know like i
think uh
in my past life i was magellan or
something
i could just see it like this no i'm not
here yes honey just just
just testing stuff out like no nya she's
probably oh my god
he thinks he's dora the explorer like an
electrician trying to try and test like
different plugs like yeah
see if it works here no she's like no
keep going and
if i find a weird spot she's like oh i
never knew
and i'm like see aren't you glad i
explored this this area
this region it's a whole new world right
here
now we just started something for
somebody else to
just make sure you get a good angle
listen it took me a while to do my hair
this morning so i hope you appreciate
all of it
you know what i like the i think the
most attractive smell
is like after a shower and fresh laundry
on does it matter what kind of soap
uh no i actually like unscented because
i like the smell
of like the natural smell of the person
yeah yeah so like if i like a girl or
whatever
a huge part of it has to also be her her
natural smell
because i think i'm really sensitive to
smell because when i smell him i'm just
like
that smells so good i want to put her
hair in my [ __ ] nose and go
yeah i got lucky i know you you know
you're doing well when you get the oh
you smell really good what are you
wearing you're like i'm not wearing
anything oh
yeah and then they're like you just
smell good and i'm like i appreciate
that i drink a lot of water so
but the hair like you know guys are like
i just want to put your hair in my face
i feel like
this [ __ ] took some time i'm gonna need
you this i was like i got
mixed girl hair we are not depressed and
then straighten
i did i posted on my instagram really i
posted on my instagram what it looked
like i'll show you guys after
but it's like a big lion's mane like
curly
yeah and that's cool i love it i wear my
hair curly all the time but
sometimes you know you need to tame the
became the beast
and it takes time and once the hair is
done and set in place then
we're not done don't don't roll down the
[ __ ] windows okay
no we're not we're not doing the oh
let's roll down the windows the hair
blowing i'm like this
no pull time so what's your hair for the
amusement parks
yeah oh i totally i love what pony but
it's the first date
first date first date sometimes i mean i
i feel like i got lucky that i could do
an updo
i know a lot of girls what's the updo
hair oh that's my favorite actually
when girls do this thing when it's like
that
and then it goes down i love that [ __ ]
that's my [ __ ] right now
yeah that style is so cute every time i
try doing it on myself i feel like five
years old
i can't do it i feel like i never know
what to do with my hair because it's
naturally curly so i would always
i had it like that last time i was here
the half up half down
that's why you look so cute that's why
you like me someone
we're just gonna come with matching hair
shelves yeah let's do it but when i go
i i'm the type i love a slick like slick
ponytail slick bun
i had to learn how to wear my hair down
i can't do messy buns
i've tried so hard it just looks messy i
can't
like it just ends up looking like not
cute what's a messy
bun i don't know so you take so a messy
bun
is when you flip your head over you take
it you put it up and it's not quite
a ponytail which would be example like
how you just did was a ponytail it's
like really like tight looking
it's like your hair is not a perfect
ballerina bun you see what ballerina
okay
it's kind of like think of a white girl
wearing hollister and
ugg boots and her hair is just up it's
like not
really done here it's not like tight up
it's kind of kind of comes out a little
bit everything yeah it's not perfect
it's like oh i just threw my hair up
because when i tried doing that there's
like those like
lump like the little yeah i don't know
how to describe it but you know what i
mean like yeah like the bowling like a
little
love and that just doesn't look good
yeah no i think it's part of the beauty
of it that it looks messy though
yeah it's like a guy having shaggy hair
it's like that's part of the look
i don't yeah it's the idea i love seeing
like other people do it i think
other people can nail it just like with
the half up
hairstyle i'm like that looks great but
when i tried doing it on myself
i can't not and not a lot of girls like
wearing ponytails like not a lot of
girls like having your because it's your
whole
face just that's your focus paul
you feel the pull it's like a facelift
instant facelift you know the girls when
they want to just be snatched that's the
whole thing like you put a nice
tight ponytail you're feeling a little
tired just pull that [ __ ] back
you know what i mean take on the world
yes that's why them girls be wearing
their ponytail so tight
really headache totally headache your
head hurt
most of the time girls heads hurt yes
they got a headache all the time that's
why we're so snappy
well if you're a dude and your head
hurts maybe you can relax by playing
some fantasy
football now is the time to celebrate
football is finally back and getting on
the action
by signing up with draftkings nothing
adds to the excitement of watching the
game
quite like having a shot at millions of
dollars in prizes draftkings is a daily
fantasy sports contest
and sports betting operator they allow
users to enter daily and weekly fantasy
sports related contests and
win money based on individual player
performances and major american sports a
lot of my friends that really really
like watching sports they have an even
better time when they play
uh fantasy football because you get to
custom pick your players and depending
on how they do
in actual in real life it reflects back
on the team that you picked that's right
and i just pulled my hair back because
i'm ready to win millions of dollars
on this damn game so download the
draftkings app
now and use code off the record for a
limited time
new users can get a free shot at
millions of dollars in prizes
with your first deposit that's called
off the record only at draftkings
make it rain minimum five dollar deposit
required
eligibility restrictions apply see
draftkings.com for details
baby nice eligibility
risk restrictions restrictions
oh man that was good yes your hair is
like
it's coming in really good that's the
samurai look you're trying to go for it
because i just need to flatten these out
he's almost done
bam and then i just want this to be a
[ __ ] bra
yeah i want to [ __ ] be like a horse
when i'm walking down the street
and then it matches with your really bad
long sideburns too
listen i got some i got some tape ins we
can make that happen
today we can actually
i know somebody who knows somebody that
can hook you up really
yeah because this part i have to grow it
out so then it can connect
down with some hair extensions i don't
care as long as it works
yeah oh yeah but then what i've been
doing is just kind of waxing
this so it stays up but then it gets all
shiny and weird what about bobby pins
or the got to be you know how the girls
put their wigs down they use the got to
be i don't know maybe this is just a me
conversation with this
that's what you know the yellow the
yellow gel i don't know what that is i
don't know what that is
okay so it's like a spiky um it's like
super thick it's like
it looks no close but
close but it's but it's like a super
sticky yes super sticky
it makes it oh i've seen it yeah yeah
yeah if you use this
you could probably get your hair to stay
slick
so you can use that instead of something
and then you spray it
and then you can have yours slick down
until it grows out oh
see this thingy yeah you use that you
put it in
and then you put the freeze spray what's
the one that the girls usually use like
the toothbrush to get the baby
that is called uh edge control edge
control
i like that in bed
that's a good one for like
this area this region normally people
who have
mixed hair that's why they created edge
control the baby hair to keep the baby
hairs in place and then you just like
smooth it down
so that they don't because normally they
don't sit with the rest of the hair
because you can tell i got mixed hair
because
i like baby hairs yeah because the
hairline gets all crazy right here
yeah sometimes because they're literally
baby hairs that don't fit with the rest
of the group
they're like they protest the rest
they're like listen [ __ ] that ponytail
and [ __ ] this part so we're just gonna
be right here
and you're gonna look messed up all day
lay me down
and it's like a wax but i don't do i
don't do my edges like
maybe every once in a while i just feel
i just like it all
back slick it all back i might get
creative but i just feel like i got an i
don't got enough face for it what the
you just like a different person though
you went from
tell me about the stock market well
right now the dow jones is pretty low
you start getting naked at the same time
start taking off
i'm going to help you with your career
are you ready we're teaming up on
we got this we got this you got to teach
yeah fans only right i'll be your first
uh uh creator on fans only yeah yeah
because we're going to create a fans
instead of all new fans you look like
[Laughter]
so you can always start with taking off
the watch first and you'll be like
but you have to start talking about
what's going on in the market today
crypto just seeing a low
uh i don't know oh that looks like
rockabilly now go the other way
no like you just flipped it no you
flipped it oh what did you do
i don't know what i did just did
something like this and it went
like a little like rockabilly-ish
now it looks like john cusack how do i
look like that
can you do a center part please oh my
god epic that's so fifth grade
yes center part fix it
all the way all the way dang your hair
is long dude you got a lot
and then what you're like yeah mushy
mushy that i got a hairbrush
yeah oh you look like a mushroom
i should do all my mushroom meetings
like this
the mushroom man do you know the
mushroom man yeah i know the mushroom
king
he does know the mushroom cookie you're
like mushroom prince and then
emo boy emojo
karen joe i have eyeliner i have
eyeliner karen joe
karin joe oh stop it no no no no no call
somebody's manager somebody's manager is
getting caught
it almost looks like the 80s band yes
and then the little like
seagulls oh my god i'm too young for you
can i see the manager
look you've messed up my starbucks order
for the last time
look at this oh that's a photo yeah it's
a carrot that's good damn dude okay
i haven't even we have to do a lot of
looks so much with her
no okay so now you have like the
pompadour thing going on when it goes
straight back see that's a whole vibe
yeah that's used to be my my favorite
jacket
that's what it is that's the old school
joke
that's the denim jacket with the levi
jeans rolled cuffed at the bottom with a
boot
you know what this one's called the
unicorn yep
i'll tell you right away the unicorn you
come riding in on that one
yep something you look like the
anglerfish the one that like
attracts the prey oh you do you attract
the girls and they come close and you
kiss them
do it again
that's for you to tickle your own nose
to make yourself sneeze
i don't know that could be used for
other things too ponytail i never
thought i would have long hair ever i
know because he used to be bald
so what made you want to grow your hair
out i couldn't go to the barber
and then i experimented with a look and
i was like
hold on and i was watching some kind of
samurai thing and i'm like
hold on let me try this and then that's
kind of where it went
i didn't know it was going to take this
long though did you actually say hold on
when you saw it
probably i was like hold on that's i got
an idea
and then it's because you know like uh
thick hair
it's difficult to come up with styles or
anything
so i didn't know what to do that's why
i've been bald for so long
that's why i shaved mine yeah i just get
so sick of it because it comes out
straight
so i just like i can't do anything until
it gets to that length i liked your hair
before when you had a comb over yeah i
looked it to it
yeah yeah yeah it's like a shorter
controller you have thick hair too
yeah super thing is it curly no i wish
it was curly
oh have you been doing something with
your beard it's like significantly
fuller
uh this side well every time i shave it
comes in thicker
but i trim the small parts now so it
looks thicker
but then this part like always curls
more so i just i just chopped it off
i think you're going to say straight i
have a beard strainer yeah
but my hair is so curly so when i when i
uh strain it it comes out like here
but it looks so thin i am all for the
men like the bald head and the beard i'm
all for that and then the guys that you
guys groom it you brush it they put
beard oil
it stays lush you yeah that's a whole
vibe
that's a look good job thank you i feel
like online it's like a mix
so people like grow their hair out shave
the beard i love people like bald head
beard i like bald head beard like you
can go all the way i think that
guys be holding on to hope for too long
and they just have to be okay
you know what i mean just let it go the
cul-de-sac has nobody living in it
like let it go nobody wants to live here
yeah did you just come up with that sure
yeah that's good that's great
i'm gonna use that yeah but you see but
you see some but you see some guys and
you're like
oh bro like i can't get a lineup ever
again
wow that's too far back what are they
gonna ride me up here why don't you do
an
old school samurai one where you grow
out the sides and then you just go
balls you shave it yeah and then you tie
it back from there
i'm just like i'm just having fun this
is just easy this is so easy yeah
do you feel like you because it's grown
out a little bit so you don't shave
every day
i don't so i go with the like the i have
my own separate yeah clippers
so i do that and then uh i don't ever go
straight yeah yeah so
you can still see that i have here i'm
not like quality baldi it's just
receding a little bit
a lot but it's just it's just
maintenance right now because i'm like i
don't want to go to barber i want to
take care of it because then when i
would do it i just
it just took too much time it'll look
bad and then i'll look good for a week
and then for like two months i'll look
like [ __ ]
yeah yeah so fellas if it's going just
let it go there's a lot let it go go to
turkey
and get the hair stuff done oh you could
do a lot
yeah but i just think that cut it off
elon did it
elon used to be bald and then he ended
up his hair grew back out of respect
though
that's true you're like yo the more
respect yeah the more hairy
yeah with the way he's going to come all
the way down here then oh [ __ ]
i know i really respect you his eyebrow
and his hairline she's just all together
noodles that's gonna go
down here so then what are you doing
wrong no respect for myself
[Laughter]
he's not respect down here right i got
the teeth done though
hell yeah
gotta bag and fix my teeth my team fix
your teeth
[Music]
you